hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it's only Jesus have you guys
seen this oh fuck that noise yeah let's
get out of here you women where women
where the hell you guys going
Mamma Mia yeah you're really going to
review Mamma Mia
yeah so what nobody's gonna watch a
fucking review of Mamma Mia yeah they're
refusing it the most hits f superheroes
fart jokes or Nicolas Cage yeah
sometimes all in the same video
it isn't just reviewing Mamma Mia I'm
tackling a subject matter that a lot of
people don't usually address yeah and
what's that I'm talking about the art of
the chick flick ah fucking crazy fucking
moron the science so you like I'm his
dignity he should have done another
matrix yeah some people got so mad they
watch that three times why do they do
that
I don't know the truth of the matter is
there is kind of an art to the chick
flick now I'm not talking about ones
that are on the spectrum like his Hunger
Games a chick flick as bridesmaids a
chick flick I'm talking about the ones
their ovaries to the wall estrogen
inducing couldn't be mistaken for
anything else
shit the same way an action film like
Harry Potter a gender neutral but
Pacific Rim is obviously a dick flick
which is like a chick flick only the
exact opposite and that's also not to
say men can't like chick flicks or women
can't like dick flakes let's not kid
ourselves it's not boys who made the
Twilight films ahead it's not girls who
made the Transformers films a Hollywood
is always going to market to repetitive
demographics when they find a pattern
that keeps repeating they're going to
exploit the fuck up but here's the thing
there's a lot of chick flicks out there
that are really good I don't care if it
mostly stars women a league of their own
is fucking hilarious
I don't care there's a lot of romance
and kissing Princess Bride still kicks
fucking ass as the years go on we see
more and more effort being put into what
was originally thought to only be a
niche market hell the highest grossing
film of all time for a while was a chick
flick and you could argue the
highest-grossing animated film right now
is a chick flick it's clear a lot more
effort is being put into them and more
and more audiences are opening
but here's what really pisses me off
when people try to use it as an excuse
when they watch something that they know
is terrible for them and it's absolute
shit but they just shrug off it's okay
it's a chick flick
fuck fuck does that matter calling a
film a gross out movie doesn't make Rob
Schneider's work any better calling a
film a video game movie doesn't make
Super Mario Brothers any better so why
does laziness and insulting writing get
a pass here well I don't think it should
case in point
mama me this is one of those chick
flicks that not only loves to use that
excuse but likes to fuck things up for
other chick flicks they're actually
trying to be smart and intelligent based
on the Broadway show every married man
over 40 was dragged to Mamma Mia is a
jukebox musical that rather than have a
variety of artists giving the off chance
you might actually like one of them
instead chooses the one your mother
listens to when she's drunk at her book
club and don't get me wrong if you like
ah but no problem they've had a lot of
big hits and they're very talented but
this is not the movie to showcase any of
their abilities this is an example of
trying to take a sub-genre in this case
the chick flick and try to resort it
down to a mathematical formula like if
you use this combination of elements
you'll end up with a demographic who
will fall for it every time
the brookheimer films use it the happy
madison films use it and you can bet
your ass this fucking film uses it I
know this because I literally found the
checklist yes
this is from the actual set of the movie
the lazy chick flick checklist a
guaranteed profitable box-office how
many of them do they check off well
let's demean women everywhere under the
guise of empowering them this is Mamma
Mia we start out by visually ripping off
another chick flick can you guess which
one as we see a girl sending off three
letters
Sam Carmichael Bill Anderson hairy
bright I just made the assumption this
movie's audience can't read so I thought
I clarify that the men get the letters
and start making their way towards
Greece as we have lazy chick flick check
number one a glittery title oh good this
is the cinematic version of those ten
year old stickers you get at grocery
stores oh yes and this brings us to lazy
chick flick check number two squeeze
actually I shouldn't say squeeing as
much as psychotically howling like
sloppily castrated hyenas I swear you
can play these cells at the end of a
horror trailer coming this fall the
squeak idiot massacre
rated E so our main character is Sophie
played by Amanda Seyfried who's about to
get married but also found her mother's
diary which gave not one not two but
three possibilities to who her mystery
father may be i chilling the island
you're so sweet and understanding I
couldn't help it and dot dot punctuation
is so wild and here's her mother played
by Meryl Streep trying once in her life
not to get an Oscar that's her I think
clearly show is always vocally imitating
a drunk Wicked Witch of the West way I'm
looking what the tide washed a serial
bride is a little herman over here where
your snot
come on I never drink and broom at the
same time we discovered that Sophie has
invited all three of her possible dads
to the wedding which is indicated in
lazy chick flick check number three
comic relief speaking in unison oh oh my
god oh you forgot do they know what you
write to a total stranger please come to
my wedding you might be my father
she sets almost as crazy as having a
musical set in Greece and yet having no
Greek star at table
ha we got a make way for Streep sisters
to come in as we partake in lazy chick
flick check number 4 you bleeding Lea
loud secret handshakes Jesus you could
just call this girl huddle the movie
come meet my backup girls trip owns a
hotel where Sophie's fiance has a
brilliant idea to attract more people
yeah you're not gonna believe this it's
really quite inspired put it online yeah
I can easily see how any business owner
would overlook that tidy step tell him
about the Internet's he's gonna put me
on the line online Oh next you'll be
telling me we have the right to vote no
one knows we're here so if I marked it
really really well then hopefully people
come flooding in we just want this to be
the ultimate romantic destination yeah
that makes sense as apart from all these
tons of people we see all the time
nobody would ever know where this place
is
and why would they it's obviously such a
low-key visually uninteresting paradise
that I'm sure word would never spread by
mouth I mean let's face it nobody ever
wants to come across a fucking shithole
like this one help
I bet the rent here is so cheap cheap
enough to support a gigantic hotel and
apparently nobody comes to I'm sorry
well fucking play out are these people
on again my sentiments exactly of course
seeing how nobody comes to this little
shack Streep has trouble keeping up with
repairs and has to do a lot of it
herself
I work all night I work all day to pay
the bills I
hey just keep in mind people Streep is
still nine voice essence away from her
into the woods quality voice so just try
to enjoy her awkward transition period
look lowly middle-aged housewives they
have the same fantasies of being rich
and full of themselves that you do I
always said Teddy as if I were a rich
man song would be made so much more
powerful if they showed him getting a
massage drinking champagne and having
hot women fan all over him
it'd just make me feel for more so
selfies dad's arrived played by Pierce
Brosnan Colin Firth and stellan
skarsgård am I saying that right do I
pronounce the other little Oh and is
ecstatic to find that she's been thrown
into an adventure of choose your own
DILF you are expecting us
oh my god yes they of course have no
idea that she's one of theirs and Sophie
being a cute charming dunderhead as
opposed to an emotionally unethical
fuckface has no idea what the hell to do
with them no come this way wouldn't say
bunny chance come to be a trouser press
about him again but I'm not done being
Colin first now this could be a
potentially funny scene Streep is about
to see not one not two but three of her
ex-boyfriends in front of her without
any warning whatsoever this could be
something like that third Rock from the
Sun episode where Don suddenly is
confronted by all his past girlfriends
recognize anybody the reaction could be
really funny hell it could be downright
hilarious so let's see what funny stuff
they have up their sleeve
you know when Wow fucking amazing that
was practically gift-wrapped for you
just about any reactions there would
have gotten a huge laugh and it's dead
what do you go for a song that
intentionally has nothing funny in it
what so ever even the song doesn't
really sum up how a person would react
after seeing that it's way too cheerful
and upbeat which falls into the most
tragic and worst of bad chick flick
writing be funny but not really anyone
that knows anything about comedy knows
that it's all based on misery there's
always an element of something negative
in it if you're going to get a laugh but
for whatever reason really bad chick
flicks think that women can't handle
actual misery so they always follow it
up with a lot of giggling for example
after her o beat song she falls right
into the middle of all this could be a
really funny setup if she freaks out or
tries to come up with a clever excuse if
there's a lot of various options you
could do to make this very humorous but
what does she do
oh it's cute it's adorable we don't
really want to get upset here we're just
having fun ah how is that funny you have
all these humorous setups here and yet
you do absolutely nothing with them
another bad shape flick that did
something similar is the Sex in the City
movie they're all checking out this guy
he's really handsome they think he's hot
but then he goes and kisses another guy
now that'd be funny if they looked
disappointed or bummed out but what do
they do oh it's silly that's fun we're
strong women so nothing upsets us
therefore absolutely nothing funny can
happen to us either we don't want to
offend you ladies because we assume that
you kind of had the mindset of toddlers
like if anything remotely threatening
happen to you but you get sad and crying
I'm also the don't worry no comedy here
nothing funny whatsoever we've replaced
all that really upsetting funny stuff
with a whole bunch of giggling because
again we kind of see you like babies if
you see a lot of women laughing even
though you don't know shit about them
maybe you
start laughing 200 everything's so
positive and upbeat here hahaha
nothing bad no reality nothing mean at
all ok it's going to be because we
respect you we respect you as smart
intelligent adults to do something
different to your hair it looks nice we
respect you we're the good chick flick
you
so steep starts to get emotional after
seeing her three baby daddies and her
friends tried to cheer her up by lazy
chick flick check number 5 dress up
clothes again kind of assuming what
amuses three-year-old girls will also
amuse grown-ass women why the fuck do
they have better Boas in a hotel anyway
um maybe I miss something but what does
being a dancing queen have to do with
the greek hotel version of Montel
Williams hey all your boyfriend's are
back and you might be ruining your
daughter's wedding but at least you can
swing those hips up almost forgot lazy
chick flick check number 6
using inanimate objects as microphones
now it does usually say it has to be a
stirring spoon or whisk but fielder will
work too will give the pass
never mind me I'm just a man with a
piano on a boat just waiting to open up
an episode of mommy Python's Flying
Circus
by I can only imagine the thousands of
dollars that went into the amazing
choreography they put in this film
I think they literally modeled it after
all the suburban mothers dancing in
their kitchens to ABBA music you know I
love these moves it makes me feel like a
Spice Girl there they're still thing
right
J we jumped in water that's deserving of
a high-five so we see Sofie interacting
with their fathers while of course not
singing a song about it at all we're not
singing a song about stuff that happened
in the past that connects very little to
what's going on now but fuck it at least
there is some character development here
among our leads they hang out together
they talk we don't hear what they're
talking about but at least they're
together they're doing something for
exactly three minutes yeah because we
have much more important things to get
to like another song that has nothing to
do with anything
this one's sung by Sophie's fiance oh
yeah there's a wedding in this movie and
a fiancee that we barely see who
apparently likes to almost burn his
future wife's head off the hell am i
watching right now
guys I could be wrong but I think we
were fucking ridiculous
you know I'm not a wedding expert or
anything but I'm just gonna take a wild
guess that the day before a wedding
people aren't quite so carefree and
happy-go-lucky I think it's usually more
my mom's causing drama now the dresses
fit and my uncle's threatening to punch
anybody who takes his flask away but if
you think this is what the day before a
wedding looks like I want what your
puppet and I'm not kidding they
literally go from one song having
nothing to do with anything immediately
into the introduction of the next song
that has nothing to do with anything no
really it's kind of amazing how much
they don't want any character in this
movie watch
look at it there wasn't even a break no
discussing anything no time to catch
your breath they just go right fucking
into it by God have we learned anything
about these characters I mean what do we
really know about Sophie nothing what do
we really know about her fiance we never
see nothing the three dads that's a joke
all we know about them is that one likes
everything in its place once more goofy
and outgoing and the other is suave and
cool those are the father's for full
house
you're so desperate you're doing
stereotypes of TGIF stereotypes oh fuck
it just let me know what Robo Oracle
comes in oh wait that'd be too
threatening don't worry ladies nothing
funny nothing funny at all we're the
good chick flick the only one who seems
to be a little developed is Streep's
character but even she has to take a
backseat to ABBA songs that obviously
aren't there to tell a story but just be
ABBA songs
okay this is the worst thing to happen
to Greece since Alexander the Great died
so the fathers are given presumably
death by snooze new as Sophie goes to
imagine actually have a meaningful
conversation with one of them look out
humanity what you drew on the boat this
is good this is really good
why don't you pursue this you have a
real talent um not to be cruel or
anything but I think that's just okay at
best I mean I don't want that getting
what's artistic sensibilities or
anything but do you really think that's
leave this place material I mean who
knows maybe there's a market out there
for people who like your cocktail napkin
drawings of Archer they are will is vast
anything can happen eventually all three
dads separately of course learn the
truth about Sophie being their daughter
and all pledged to be there for this big
surprise is a little much for Sophie to
take in what a shock and here I thought
inviting my feet on no dance I never
meant to meet up the weekend of my
wedding without telling anybody dealing
with other common wedding drama would
cause no problem whatsoever oh I only
hope there's a novice on and this will
be about being a fucking mental
masochist
but nope instead we're cutting to stupid
shit like this man
even by bad chick-flick standards that
was uncomfortably forced to shrug under
protest that we are better as a species
but Brosnan tries to see if he can make
things better it used to be so nice oh
wow oh wow yeah all those happy days
they seemed so hard to fight he's
singing so bad even Streep doesn't know
how to take it in Ritu you
virtual closed your mind
oh yes thank God drown me out music more
background singers auto-tuning can only
save me so much
Jesus was a dr at a karaoke poem after
20 guinnesses you're making sure our
Butler sound like idina menzel okay
movie don't make me do that again okay
we're back to Sophie maybe now we can
finally get into her mindset see what
the hell's going to making up where we
left off last night
the focus looks a neocon ignore the
chemistry between us you're so hot
teasing me nope but seriously where the
hell is this coming from this is
literally the first time we've seen this
guy and he's not even hitting on a main
character why are we focusing on this
there's that look in your eye hell does
this have to do tell me what's happening
okay
I know jukebox musicals have to
incorporate their story to songs that
already exist but this isn't
incorporating them this is writing
around them this is dropping a roadblock
of creativity to your nads I mean it's
not like don't make me say it don't make
me say it movie god damn it don't make
me say it
I I can't I can't like I said please
don't make me say this it's not like
Moulin Rouge where the songs actually
tied in yeah that's how bad we've gotten
people you're forcing me to compliment
Moulin Rouge I feel so dirty but it is
true they at least tried to tie in the
songs to the story they were telling
this this is tying it in as much as say
a Six Flags musical stage show for your
five-year-olds it doesn't have to make
sense it just has to be happy and
mindless while you catch your breath
from the real entertainment only here
this is the real entertainment
John it's like being the designated
driver at Satan's bachelorette party
which I'm not really sure Satan's female
or not but after seeing this film I'm
willing to lean towards he probably is
we done good holy Sh you make me want to
pee myself I was terrible
so Sophie meets up with her fiance and
lets him know what she's done I thought
that I would know my dad right away but
I didn't I just I have no idea you
invited these guys for you didn't tell
me no I thought you would you trust op
me
I thought you used logic and stuff that
doesn't usually find a bad chick flick
he rightfully calls her a twat and she
goes to her mother to figure out what to
do will you help me I want to sing a
song about my emotions I was thinking
about the Monster Mash she ties it about
as much as any of the other songs do in
all fairness we do surprisingly get a
song that does kind of connect to what's
going on as Streep sings about letting
her daughter go it's actually one of the
few genuinely emotional moments in the
entire film
thank God they botch it up just a few
moments later
but you see
okay by this point Streep's then at
least passable the in the singing depart
nothing great
nothing terrible but what the heck you
gotta give her a repentance but here you
really have to stretch your vocal chaps
in order to make it sound good and it's
simple
god bless her she looks nice against
that background
when I take
yeah she may have given Bronson to look
before but now it's clearly history
spectators at ooh yeah I uh
let's do each other favorable fire
agents
Stella find us better boys teachers so
the wedding finally gets underway and
she's about to marry Saturday Night
Fever here but big shock Streep wants to
steal the spotlight part taking in yet
another lazy chick flick Lachey
interrupting a wedding I have to tell
you he is here I know I invited him we
can find out if you want but being a
third of your dad is scraped by me let
me - I'll take a third so Merrill is
shocked to find that in a bizarre way
she's reliving Sophie's Choice as we
discover that oh I can't even say it
just watch no clue which one of you is
my dad but I don't mind Skye let's just
not get married yet let's just get all
this I wanted to see the world okay
right I love you to everyone who spent a
fortune coming out here my fiance's
parents who spent a fortune on this
wedding and my mother spent the other
half of the fortune on this wedding
I offer you my sincerest fuck yous in
the ass have a nice trip back but it's
okay because me partaken lazy chick
flick check number who the fuck's even
counting anymore unrealistic happy
ending that would be a positively
terrible ending in real life oh wait it
gets better
why waste a good wedding
though by religious standards who broken
God knows how many qualifications for
our Catholic mayor so enjoy these words
that mean absolutely nothing they have
the reception and we finally wrap up on
our Malta if you change what what what
is this
movie you're over shut the fuck up no
there is literally nothing else to sing
about you've already had one pointless
song dedicated to a side character
anymore in the audience is gonna stab
their ears out with sharpened platforms
shows we can go watch game this week
okay can someone just give me something
really manly here for a second
swallow this thank you
so some he's not getting married but is
happy to know she's now getting triple
the presents on her birthday and that
finally seems to wrap up on him oh
Christ it has more ending so much credit
a cake
now I see the credits rolling that means
I can stop good I don't wanna see any
more of my three ants partaking in
drunken karaoke
you know what neither should you even if
you're an Abba fan this movie is just
awful I've never seen a more pointless
reason to use a band songs it doesn't
further any story fuel any emotion or
make us understand anything about any of
the characters
I don't see how this product could have
been saved in a way I'm glad the
director went on to stronger work
because I don't know how anybody could
have pulled this film off in a good way
there are good chick flicks out there
ones that are smart funny dramatic even
groundbreaking this is the nightmare
that everybody thinks a chick flick is
and all I gotta say is thank God better
films are coming out with more
intelligence and thought because this is
pure shit but I'll give them a movie
this it did make me want to go to Greece
and apologize to everybody there for
this film being made he's speaking of
moving weird everybody go anyway hey
guys what you working on oh well since
no one's gonna see this review we
decided to write down all the things
that normally ruin our careers oh my god
do you mean any of it oh no we just say
it cuz we won't get in trouble for it
yeah go ahead say something terrible to
everyone but I can't do that I'd be
nothing without these people oh come on
you pussy nobody's watching anyway like
screaming into a pillow you think so oh
yeah you'll feel much better letting out
your aggression on nobody okay so you
want me to point to all the viewers at
home the the ones that allow me to make
a living doing what I love huh
you want me to point to all them and
just say the most terrible horrible
thing I can think of like you're all
hey kiss my mommy had a bigger fan base
than I thought
you
my god